hey reject nation how you doing Greg
John we're gonna watch the end of rack
or racket not clickbait Oh
some people theorize this might be an
April Fool's video but it came out today
April 2nd there's no more foolishness on
a second business in the second I'd out
of their channels ending maybe it's just
like the house of Rack is ending or
something like that which is a bummer I
was such a big part of their channel for
a while know that 1m they've entered
into a suicide pact and they're going to
hard-code I think that they've been
having a lot of issues with YouTube
because the kind of content they produce
a violence in vulgarity so you know your
content they do see what this is all
about big bro because the thing is we
actually got of this monster scary
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Temari you run through first and if
Danny wants to be second I'll hit it
with a gyproc tomorrow
whoa
I was
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's an exclusive never forget Hausa
brackish are also available link in
description smell
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
why don't we say voice and quick and
this operations already taken about 20
minutes so if you gonna come around come
around but this is the final night
actually is pretty simple
absolutely it would have to be gone in
like under 10 hours I get this weird
feeling I literally it's like the end of
everything
people would eat you I feel like we're
done with YouTube or something they
don't want us on the platform
what's the plan what's happening we
can't survive for this platform just
like Oh they've worked on this platform
we're going to use making this Berk fun
one lasted YouTube sorry
oh [ __ ] that's a trying man to Mandy's
drunk right now and he's giving DM I'm
literally older than my room and then
like we'll just finished filming
everything well and I love seriously
crying I can't believe just everything
that's happening it's just like like
what's been happening what are you
talking about experiences just like this
is my total dream my just living you
guys it's just like so amazing I get to
live my best friends and I get to
expense everything that I ever wanted to
I can be my eyesight it is a dream so I
cool like I like a dream that's
seriously what because you guys thanks
we love you Mandy
I love you too fireman what's
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
mommy daddy Richie
ha
[Music]
damn
[Music]
huh
I never thought in a million years of
rock or rock video would get material
could be so endearing and so touching
well it's like I feel like they're what
they do just became like fully
understand if you didn't fully
understand who they are like they became
more understood from this one video his
Rack Arrakis content is so specific and
yeah I remember when they got the house
it was kind of surprising to me because
YouTube had gone through its algorithm
change that's a few months later they
went through their ad pocalypse portion
and then when they were bringing back
ads again and to youtube I was on that
side of spectrum like how are they going
to make it yeah all their stuff is super
mature and and usually they violent
violent very bitter yeah almost like
jackass in a way it's like a more
violent sketch version of jacket yeah
exactly
but the house of rakha allows you to
open up to these guys weigh them more
like jackass but it also got you to see
that these are this is just a group of
people that just love having fun and
they do what damages so let it translate
to the camera even if you only see their
sketches and stuff you might have a
season to dismiss these guys as a bunch
of goofballs but these guys are hard-ass
workers yeah work their asses off that's
part of the cool mystique about these
dudes is it looks like they're not they
don't really work yeah really they do
they work their asses off this is like
the definition of controlled chaos Danny
is like it all appears very off-the-cuff
and even the way they've been editing
these house of rack of videos you'll
have these like weird interstitials and
stuff and then you'll have stuff it's
like pretty regular and then it'll turn
into a sketch I thought what they were
doing with that was really clever
they're terrific at like doing stunts
and doing effects and you know yeah
practical work with you know props and
things they put in a lot of hard work in
the last like few minutes of this you
get to see their heart and I feel like
that's something you don't really get a
good amount of when it comes to Rack
Iraq because they're mainly about it to
its humor the heartfelt side they don't
have the bromance have the friendships
they all have when that one dude started
like tearing up talking about like how
he's gonna miss all this I'm sure this
was a big dream come true like hey we're
all gonna get a house together all the
success we've had we can finally do this
and sure enough some terrible YouTube
stuff starts happening and now they're
in this position now they
not welcoming anymore I don't think they
have real thing they don't have to add
their Channel the couple that have been
doing like movie work and stuff so maybe
they have other things lined up yeah
because it seems like you seemed really
sincere when he was saying like you two
we're going to go broke if we stick with
YouTube you know I can see a lot of
people we know yeah I mean that has got
to be a lot to pay for and also you know
I imagine that their videos aren't
always cheap to assemble because you
know they go out places and shoot so I
don't know what the laws are there but
you know permits and props and things
they're breaking and destroying and I'm
sure it's it's probably has more upkeep
and more overhead than we think it does
yes yes they have an editor and stuff
everywhere everyone has to be getting
paid for yeah they're doing I really am
but for them because there's so there's
such a fun channel there they're one of
those channels where I've watched plenty
of their videos on my own time or I've
shared their sketches of a lot of my
friends like you see raka raka I got to
show you some of their videos they're an
example of something that you can you
that they're an example of something
that can uniquely grow out of something
like a YouTube which is partly why it's
so sad to see that the if the platform
has become so hostile about these things
yeah cuz this is a narrowing of the
kinds of things I'm gonna see you know
yeah you gotta tube got to be more
advertiser friendly now and all these
things more corporate more corporate to
keep up with the Tonight Show and
[Music]
there's no outlet for those things
before Greg where could I have seen
Conan before I feel like they'll still
probably do their sketches and if they
start a patreon I feel like they'd be
just fine because I'm sure they get
plenty of supporters they still got
millions of followers it says the end of
Rack Iraq but I wouldn't be surprised if
rack Iraq I lived on in some form they
should and I'm sure that in light of
this video somebody's gonna swoop in and
make things happen in some way I'm sure
they're gonna get calls from people
maybe if it's not rack a rack of moving
for it I'm sure we'll see these dudes
again man this is really heartfelt and
I'm bumper for these guys I would love
it if it wasn't April Fool's we're just
not really bother
yeah well I mean what time of day did
this publish because maybe they
published it on April 3rd ahead of ours
yeah they're way ahead of ours yeah
they're way ahead of our time so this
could be April Fool the problem is I
believe it but if you told me it was a
joke I would also believe yeah
especially that montage the end is so
like Oh like yeah I was like oh they're
gonna do some joke they're gonna do some
like ending sketch they put heart into
their work with their heart isn't as
front and center it's they're never
gonna overtly show it to ya and this one
they did that yeah and I was like oh wow
you know it's been there the whole time
we just didn't really pony in on that
date away yeah
Ronald can't die all right I still show
people their style all right guys well
subscribe to raka raka first and
foremost if you haven't already you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell love to have you
be a part of our world
you